and gentlemen black helicopters have
been spotted oh you want me to tell you
something that's the first guy could say
that like throw a couple weeks ago I
went back to my hotel room the [ __ ]
original getaway it was on with Steve
McQueen and I forgot bro I forgot do you
forget your road and look I get tears of
my eyes he's in the dumpster with that
[ __ ] after the thing tripped him over
and she's [ __ ] telling them all
he's like well we should just break ways
and she's like well obviously you can't
get over me having sex with somebody
else at you're a mental [ __ ] folk and
Steve McQueen bro he just grabbed her by
the hand you and then he goes back to
the hotel he shoots all those [ __ ]
rednecks oh we forget how bad Steve
McQueen we look at him look at this
[ __ ] look at this [ __ ] man of a
man that he was there's my man salaat so
from the Godfather watch Steve McQueen
with a [ __ ] suit on this is 1973 dog
he's so smooth this is not the scene you
got to put on the scene is when he beats
up Ali MacGraw and she thought it was
acting and he just liveth he breathed
pretty much smack the [ __ ] out she
didn't know but he would smack the [ __ ]
out of every other day for some reason
or another he was like good he was like
John let her up
yes watch my scene bro you just have
funny John this funny feeling where we
talked about music I don't believe in
violence but if I was married to Yoko
Ono you know you got a kick out once a
day somewhere in the back and the
stomach shut the [ __ ] up see in fact he
was crying I look how beautiful this
woman was number one look at the natural
beauty on this [ __ ] woman and look at
this blonde savage of a man look at them
he's [ __ ] low Steve McQueen gets out
of the car and just starts walking in
front of the car does he smack her after
this watch he looks like he had two
beautiful that right look at him with
his black suit on he's furious fine hair
wear my hair like that yes I would me
too my head start to fall I upper Grey's
igloo I figured out the time you don't
wanna lose handle crazy little more
won't go nowhere she's getting out of
car she looks upset this is very
emotional
yeah look at four years is 72 I was nine
I went to see this the first weekend my
mother goes what you get to see Steve
McQueen are you [ __ ] crazy Wow oh
Jesus Christ
oh dude he's hitting there for real she
didn't know she's gonna get hit she
didn't know oh my god [ __ ] man
Jesus man you're always last time you
saw that you got to see this [ __ ] and if
you really want to see a beatin you got
to pull up and the longest year I were
Burt Reynolds in the beginning when he
grabs him by the throat and hits her
with the bottle of something
this is Burt when we watch it here just
this is [ __ ] up because it was crazy
you you you know he's really hitting her
yeah I was until her 10-times he told
her I wanted her it's like when Sean
Penn did that close range with with
whatever and he kept shooting a gun and
finally Sean Pangos give it a gun
because you're not reacting the right
way you're not being scared so he shot a
real gun at Christopher Walken
Christopher Walken talks about all the
time look at this [ __ ] Savage go no
off of me my god how the movie opens
this [ __ ] Jesus Christ Jesus Christ it's
amazing what 40 years has done yeah pill
use a BB a lot how beautiful she was us
Beauty verse eating I'm splitting man
look at his body though this guy was not
juicing this guy is [ __ ] nuts
you all-american son of a [ __ ] yeah
this is like a soap opera from Mexico no
no no this is [ __ ] soap opera from
Mexico bro totally is ha ha ha it's only
good so remember the 70s everybody had
booze net and TV everybody look at
everybody's house had booze botella Mira
miss Oh Burt Reynolds guiity yeah
well well
Wow
so hostile oh my god she bit him
Oh some through some [ __ ] this is a
Mexican soap opera song here we go just
comes Jesus man oh he's got a fake
slapped this oh my god that was a real
throw that real throw that's where the
ground seems super real that would hurt
your hip that's a hard floor didn't even
give her a cushion man like look at
what's going on yeah there was an
actress I'm high resolution yeah would
you let Burt Reynolds throw you to the
ground no [ __ ] no no I bet here dude
getting thrown to now hurts that [ __ ]
hurts like she just ricocheted off the
ground 100% that wasn't a stunt person
yeah geez York often stuff not just
weird question out dog gets into his car
super weird
he starts it up Joe Rogan Joe Rogan you
ready for this he gets in his [ __ ]
without and begins he starts it up and I
was on your here Saturday night [ __ ]
Lennox kid it turns out he's so well
alright I'm going to play that part
oh my god yeah yeah as soon as then he
gets this crossed watch the car and
that's what's on the rate what here we
go Burt Reynolds
me eight oh yeah oh you knew you aren't
the right baby lack of black had to tell
ya leave that [ __ ] box that's a Maserati
it's like an Avanti it's about that's
hilarious
whoa the cops she called the cops I
laugh at all whoa doh that car is so
fast oh my god
meanwhile that car handles like total
dog [ __ ] what is it I don't know but I
mean those cars back then even the best
ones handled like [ __ ] that thing has
skinny tires a [ __ ] caveman
suspension but it probably did drive a
lot better than those police cars though
police cars like the worst cars you
could drive you're trying to catch
somebody have four doors you want to
cart it as two doors as you know yeah
Ford's car it's got a good balance and
something go around corners quick with
you know like race cars aren't big long
for doors it's a lot of extra weight
it's not yeah I haven't like a police
car like but today they have police cars
today they like they can make like
Mustangs they turn them into police cars
yeah charger yeah yeah dude there's some
scary cars today when it comes to like a
car pulling you over like if the cops
have that new dodge demon who've seen
that thing yeah that's [ __ ] nuts
800 horsepower zero to 60 in like two
seconds
really [ __ ] crazy it's it's so stupid
[Applause]
[Music]